ولما نقول الارجنتين اوتوماتيك لي يعني
مرادف لها هو ميسي هذا اللاعب طبعا
الاسطوره الي امستحقق انجاز كان ناقص
سلسله طويله من انجازاته فخلال مسيره
مستمره اكثر من 30 سنه مسي فاز ب 37 لقب
مع انديته برشلونه وباريس سان جيرمان
وميسي الكره الذهبيه سبع مرات اكثر من اي
لاعب اخر وفاز بالحذاء الذهبي لافضل
الهداف في اوروبا ست مرات ومع المنتخب فاز
بكوبا امريكا وفاز معه كمان من ميداليه
ذهبيه اولمبيه هذا غير سلسله طويله من
الارقام القياسيه في التهديف والاحصائيات
المذهله كل هذه الانجازات كان ناقصها بس
كاس العالم وهذا حقق ميسي امس مع تسمى
كمان افضل لاعب في البطوله ومن وقتها
والاحتفالات شغاله وطبعا المقارنات مع
الاسطوره مارادونا اللي كان اخر من جاب
اللقب للارجنتين من 36 سنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تحقيق نفسي لقب كاس العالم
في العالم بيتخانقوا عليه اكيد طبعا عرفته
اللاعبين يعني اساطير في اللعبه وعنده
تاريخ ارقام طويله جدا لكن الاثنين كان
ناقصهم كاس العالم ميسي رونالدو
احنا سالنا مجموعه من الصحفيين والمحللين
الرياضيين وهذي كانت اجاباتتهم
اللي مثل يقدر يعمله انا شايفه ان هو ما
فيش حد ثاني هيعرف يعمل اللي هو قادر
يعمله بالطريقه دي لان هو الموجبه اللي
عنده يعني رونالدو جسمه قوي جسمه يعني
حاجه فاز القدرات اللي عنده فيزيك لي حاجه
فازقه مسي- بجسمه صغير بالسكين والثالث
الموهبه اللي هو اللي اتولد بها بيعمل
حاجات مرعبه ان هو يبقى عنده 35 سنه ويقدر
يحقق حلم بقى له سنين طويله جدا بيحاول
يعمله همم حاجه همم تتسجل له يعني التاريخ
لو لازم اختار هاقول ان مثلا هو اعظم لاعب
في التاريخ كسب كل حاجه ممكن يكسبها في
الكوره من دوري في اسبانيا الى دوري
الابطال دوري دوري الانديه كاس العالم
الانديه
كاس العالم
كاس العالم ممكن بعد يقول اه ممكن بعد
يقول لا بالنسبه اه مش بس عشان احقق كاس
العالم اللقب الوحيد اللي كان فاضل له
عشان يختم اللعبه زي ما الناس بتقول لكن
بالنسبه لي لان ميسي ما فيش لاعب في
العالم حاليا بيتفوق عليه في الارقام او
البطولات الجماعيه او البطولات الفرديه او
الارقام الشخصيه الفرديه والجماعيه في
الفتره الاخيره
في المستقبل همم لانه ببساطه في نقاش
مماثل لم يتم حسمه عبر 10 سنوات الماضيه
ما بين مارادونا
فاهمين فيهم الافضل طبيعي انه همم يبقى
النقاش ده موجود بسبب الشعبيه الجاربها
والنتائج المذهله والارقام المذهله
للنجمين همم وفي النهايه هو لقب معنوي
الجماهير بتمنحه للعب المفضل بتاعها واللي
بتحبه واللي بترى ان هو الافضل الجدل حول
الافضل على مر العصور لا يمكن ان يحسب لكن
الامر الذي يحسن بان ميسي دخل من الافضل
على المره العصور يعني اصبح في قائمه
طويله من الافضل
الابطال القوميين التاريخيين صحه التسميه
مثل مارادونا وبيليه وهم الاشهر طبعا ميسي
الان اصبح معهم ومشجعوه يعني يطلقون هذه
التسميه وهم مرتاحه لكن الجدل لن يحسب
سؤالك عن رايه فانا ارى ميسي هو الافضل
عبر التاريخ
ويستحق ان يكون الافضل الوجود في زمن صعب
في كره القدم ليس مثل زمن مارادونا
والصحفيين منهم اللي احتاروا منهم اللي
قال صعب اختزال اللقب في شخص واحد واخرين
شافوا الموضوع بيعتمد عليك كثير اشياء
يبدو انه الجمهور العام رايك كان اكثر
وضوحا ليه بقول كده لانه احنا عملنا تجربه
صغيره وسالناكم في استفتاء على حسابنا على
تويتر لو برايكم بس خلاص كده الافضل الان
صار على مر العصور والنتيجه كانت بفارق
بسيط اكثر من 66% شايفين انه نعم هو
الافضل عبر العصور والباقي شايفين انه لا